hi my name's Lucy Johnston I'm a
clinical psychologist I've worked in the
NHS for many years in mental health
teams and I'm currently describing
myself as an independent writer and
trainer you hold a very unorthodox view
that actually psychiatric disorders and
diagnosis are not the best way to go
about engaging with mental health well
it used to be very unorthodox view it's
becoming less unorthodox and one of the
things that I think a lot of people
don't realize is that this is changed a
bit from being seen as a rather extreme
strains position and actually even the
very senior clinicians who put together
the list of psychiatric disorders and
illnesses which appear in great big
books call things like DSM and ICD are
openly saying that this isn't really
working that these are not proper
scientific categories that we need to I
mean essentially tear that up and start
again so it's much less unorthodox than
it used to be there's a growing number
of people myself and other professionals
but also people have been through
services themselves saying this wasn't a
helpful way of understanding my distress
you know my distress is very real
nobody's denying that but actually there
are better ways of understanding it and
there are significant disadvantages to
giving people a diagnostic label and
then kind of embarking on the whole
journey of I've got a mental illness
with everything that that implants and
what are these better ways of addressing
mental health issues I'm in those
various ways that you could look at
things from a non diagnostic perspective
and yeah there's a number of people and
projects and types of therapy that have
always done that from a psychologists
point of view we like to use a
particular approach which is called
formulation which is a little bit of a
jargon word but essentially what that
means is that it's a way of putting
together someone's score
and the way that usually happens is that
you sit down with a psychologist or
perhaps another professional over a
period of weeks or months sometimes
longer and the professional brings their
knowledge of evidence and of other
people they've worked with their
clinical experience the client or
service user brings of course their
knowledge of their life and what
happened and what it felt like and what
it meant to them and how it's affected
them and if you put those two forms of
evidence together you can come up with a
kind of personal story it's like a
personal best guess if you like so these
things happened this is what it felt
like this is what it meant to you this
is how you tried to survive and cope
with it all so a formulation if it's
done properly of course it can be done
badly as well as helpfully is a kind of
map to your personal journey if you like
so my argument and the argument of a lot
of psychologists would be that diagnosis
doesn't really suggest a way forward but
a formulation can suggest a very
personal way forward that makes sense of
your experiences and your story leads to
quite a personal plan about what it's
likely to be helpful for you it sounds
like this is more collaborative and
gives more agency to the patient so that
it's not like a top-down approach where
a specialist tells you what you have and
then yeah you just have to take a purlin
kind of the element that's exactly it
it's not or it shouldn't be an expert
driven process almost by definition a
diagnosis is something an expert gives
you or perhaps in psychiatry often
imposes on you because try to disagree
and you'll find that often that's not
possible whereas a formulation is
certainly meant to be much more
collaborative you and me thinking
together and of course that gives you
more choice and more control we hope we
hope it helps you to feel that you've
been listened to that someone really
gets you someone can see things on your
point of view we hope it gives a message
of you know encouragement for the future
because a storm you nation is also about
what you can do what your strengths are
what you see
seated in what skills you have and so
ideally if a person goes Ward feeling
well I'm not just a bundle of problems
I'm feeling this way and reacting this
way for very good reasons
anybody else who'd been through the same
circumstances might be feeding and
behaving exactly the same way but I
think I have a better understanding of
it and I can see how I could move
forward that's the ideal and then you
said that it depends on whether the
formulation is being done well or not
what what kind of factors or well what
would mean a formulation done well and
how can can the process work more
effectively what does that mean in fact
a so I do a lot of training in
formulation and I've been part of the
group setting up good practice
guidelines for how to do affiliation
sensitivity effectively for
psychologists my professional body the
division of clinical psychology so it's
kind of obvious things in a way you know
clearly you could have someone who came
along insensitively and asked questions
that felt too personal or difficult or
painful it's a particular time who came
along full of their ideas not your ideas
and clearly it's better if you couldn't
be really sensitive to what someones
were able to talk about at the moment
happy to talk about the moment sensitive
to the relationship between you so you
can build up trust sensitive to really
listening to what the person is saying
not coming in with your own ideas and
the idea of a formulation is that it's
always open to change so sensitive to
being able to say this is only my guess
or our guests have we got it right do we
need to alter it do we need to revisit
it and the guiding person in that has to
be the person themselves and is this
borrowing a bit from psychoanalysis it's
I guess it's boring from therapies in
general not particularly psychoanalysis
but all therapies in a way or engaged in
the process of trying to make sense out
of someone's story so formulation can be
part of almost any therapeutic approach
whether it's CBT or systemic approaches
or I suppose psychoanalytic approaches
in a way it's just a way of structuring
what is likely for going some level in
area therapeutic relationship and
process but I think there are some clear
advantages to kind of getting it out on
the table and that's partly because you
can both really check you're on the same
track the person whose story tears
couldn't really feel they've got control
and ownership of it you could put things
right if they don't seem to quite fit
and you can use it use it as a shared
map and way forward and are there any
particular situations in which
formulations are better to apply than
others so for instance I'm thinking that
there might be a lot of skeptics about
applying this to more serious mental
health issues like what is called
schizophrenia or a psychotic disorder
okay
so I've worked a lot with people those
diagnoses in fact that's been where a
large part of my work has been so I
would say absolutely it is the case that
formulation is extremely helpful in
those situations too because a cool
message of a formulation really is that
however apparently unusual and extreme
and overwhelming someone's thoughts
feelings and behaviors are there is a
way of making sense of it but I think
what I would say is that obviously if
some people who are extremely distressed
and confused and really not able to sit
down and put things into words
of course you don't kind of plunge in if
you like of course that may be a slower
and more gentle process but certainly I
would there's a great deal of research
to show that even the things that we
call things like schizophrenia which is
not a term I would use and the psychosis
which is not a term I would use that
actually the causal factors in those
kind of experiences you know very
similar to the calls or processes in
things that we would call anxiety and
depression you know there may be more
difficult events they may be of a more
extreme type but essentially it's a
range of people dealing with
stories you know in a range of different
ways of the stories can be very extreme
of course but the consequences I think
are always understandable so in other
words am as some mental health activists
have put it doctors should and
therapists should ask the question what
has happened to you rather than what's
wrong with you you've got it in one it's
the big shift from asking what's wrong
with you to us being what's happened to
you
that is a quite a well-known slogan from
what is called a trauma-informed
approach which is all about the growing
amount of evidence about the often
devastating impact of trauma and
adversity of all kinds on our emotions
on our feelings or not on our bodies as
well and the essence of the approach is
not what's wrong with you but what's
happened to you and but at the same time
people with similar experiences can then
end up feeling very differently about
about those experiences were what kind
of factors determine whether someone who
has had who's not being traumatized as a
child both by the same thing and as a
happy individual and someone else ends
up suffering a lot okay that's a good
question because it's important not fall
into the trap of thinking this awful
thing happened to me as a child I'm
doomed to have mental health problems or
to have a miserable desperate life that
really isn't the case and what does it
mean to successfully assist to
successfully um and the treatment or
like what is the goal of over treatment
that involves formulation clues for
instance with and had other therapists
with whom we've talked here who were
saying that a lot of psychiatrists think
that the end goal of the treatment is to
get rid of the symptoms but actually a
lot of patients report that what they
want is to feel valued in society and
even if that means hearing voices still
stays with them it's not a problem as
long as they
Valene that's true if you have a medical
approach then almost by definition
you're saying treatment
ideally leads to cure which means no
symptoms and I wouldn't use any of those
words actually treatment cure or
symptoms if this is about coming to
terms with difficult life events then
again this is kind of common sense we
all know there are things that you never
get over in the sense of forgetting
about them and then having no impact on
you but you can reach a point where it's
not dominating your life and where
you're living a full and fulfilling and
you know in life which you feel is
meaningful and you have friends and
perhaps family and you know your life is
continuing it hasn't got stuck at the
point at which the difficult things
happened and for some people for quite a
few people that may mean continue to
have what in psychiatric terms of good
symptomless
so you may for example continue to hear
voices but one of the things that can
happen and I know a number of people who
would confirm this you may have talked
to them as well it might be the case
that the voices turned from being
hostile and abusive and overwhelming to
actually being supportive and actually
you can build a different relationship
with your voices in such a way that they
become a valued part of you so they
don't vanish but they can actually you
know be a new part of your identity in
your life in a way that is allowing your
still to live your life how long does
this therapy involving formulation
normally and take and if there's a
variety what does what kind of lengths
are we okay so I think as I said
formulation could be part of a number of
different therapies and some of them are
typically time limited like CBT some of
the ones and I think I'd also like to
say that the simulation doesn't
necessarily have to imply therapy you
know there's a whole lot of other ways
people may want to join self-help groups
may want to get more involved in their
communities you know may want to take up
sport or exercise or art or you know all
sorts of ways people can move forward
and heal but some people will want to do
therapy as
part of that process and you know it's a
how long is a piece of string but I
think in general we are guilty in the
Health Service of thinking you know
setting to narrow limits of its you
cannot say 16 sessions and that's it
yeah the many people it's been longer
for people who suffered more severe
forms of abuse and trauma then you could
easily be talking two years three years
and that sounds a lot but it's much more
costly and will cost in every sentence
time money not to give people help they
want that's the situation in which
people can turn into long-term
psychiatric patients and you've just
mentioned that in addition to therapy
formulations could work well with like
taking art or sport or community work so
with would this be just and the
formulation would be like a kind of a
few sessions in which um someone could
work with a person who's struggling and
then decide together that they should be
taking up sport for instance or what
exactly do you mean how would the two
work together
outside the context of therapy okay so I
think sometimes formulation can be just
a one-off and can be quite helpful and
before you've put together this map you
can't work out what the best way forward
is going to be because the formulation
is going to tell you so it might be that
if you've jointly put together a
formulation someone who says well
actually I can see that at some point I
might need to do some work on this which
is going to be quite painful but at the
moment I really really am NOT up for it
and my life isn't in the right kind of
stable state for you to do that work so
in the short term I might like to do
this this is this instead so that's one
possibility
so you know ideally formulation is
flexible enough to accommodate a whole
range of things you know that may or may
not include therapy you've mentioned
throughout the interview certain words
that you don't really want to use that
are associated with them with mental
health or our part of our vocabulary at
the moment and surrounding mental health
and I don't like the word mental health
either
really
okay so and so maybe you could run us
through a series of terms that you think
are wrong and propose alternatives for
each of them I mean the reason I'm a bit
hung up on language is because we use
the language of medical thinking so
uncritically in what what I wouldn't
call mental health but it is officially
called a mental health system so if you
use a word like illness or disorder or
symptom location or treatment or cure or
prognosis or you know there's a whole
range of words all of those actually
imply that we're dealing with medical
illnesses and unless you're quite
careful about language I think that
assumption kind of creeps in it creeps
in we really need to change your
thinking in this area because the
medical approach is so deeply embedded
in our whole way of thinking and that's
not just mental health professionals
it's everybody what do you read in the
media everybody thinks there's such a
thing as a medical illness called
psychosis or schizophrenia or clinical
depression you know there isn't
particularly thinks there is and one of
the most effective ways of challenging
that is to be very careful about your
language change the way you talk you are
forced to challenge some of your
assumptions so what do you do instead
and this is a very controversial issue
by the way lots of people don't like
language being challenged but I mean
everyone can choose that arm language of
course they can but I think it has to be
an open choice and an informal choice
and if we're all automatically using
medical language in effect we're
depriving people of other choices so my
argument and the argument of many other
people who I work with would be to use
the most ordinary everyday neutral
language we can so I will use ordinary
words like extreme distress or emotional
suffering or extreme states or problems
or difficulties or struggles or recovery
or healing and there's not a single set
of words to replace the ones we have but
there's a you know there's ordinary
language words which we all understand
which don't imply medic
and you also use the word story a lot we
talk about that a bit about that why is
it important to have a kind of coherent
story that about one's life okay so if
you asked me in very simply as people
sometimes do what's the alternative to
diagnosis I would say it's listening to
people's stories so stories one word
narrative is another word formulation is
a particular kind of story but in
essence I think what's most damaging
about diagnosis is that it skews
people's personal stories you know
everybody comes along to mental health
services or experiences distress without
coming over to services for reasons in
their lives everybody has a story and if
you impose a diagnosis in effect you're
shutting down that story you're saying
it's because you've got whatever it is
bipolar disorder but it's now disorder
clinical depression as soon as you say
that you tend to stop asking and you've
got this false explanation which sounds
like an explanation it isn't why are you
feeling so MS real desperate because
you've got clinical depression how do we
know you've got clinical depression
because you're feeling miserable and
desperate why are you having the
terrible mood swings because you have
bipolar disorder how do they've got my
purchase order because you're having
these terrible mood swings and
underneath all those labels there will
be stories and I have a particular
interest in formulation but I'm more
generally uninterested in and supportive
of any type of storytelling any type of
narrative I think formulation works
quite well in services because it's got
some credibility and some research to
support it but in general if it makes
sense to you to think about your story
through art or through poetry or through
music or through you know community
rituals or myths and legends many of
which still exist as a way of making
sense of distress in parts of the world
that haven't yet been colonized by our
diagnostic model you know all of that is
great it's kind of what works and make
sense for you really I'm I'm speaking of
other cultures and have you looked at
the way
other cultures deal with distress and
what we could learn yeah I have to an
extent and part of have done that is
through a project I've been involved in
which I could mention if that's
appropriate so for the last five or six
years I've been involved in a very major
project that is attempting to outline
what would a non diagnostic
understanding of distress looks like
because although we have a number of
examples of what you might do
differently one to one what we're
lacking I think I have been lacking is a
really coherent whole conceptual model
whole way of thinking that could
actually replace diagnostic medical
thinking so there's a core group of nine
of us psychologists and people who call
them survivors at the psychiatric system
together with a number of others who
were funded by the division of clinical
psychology which is my professional body
to undertake this crazily ambitious
project which ended up 200 thousand
words long but there are shorter and
more accessible versions and in essence
it's called the power threat meaning
framework so if you google power threat
meaning framework and British
Psychological Society you'll find all
the resources the documents videos short
versions whatever else you might be
interested in so in a way the essence of
that is establishing that narratives are
valid and evidence way based way and an
important way and a healing way at
replacing diagnosis and as part of that
we looked across different cultures to
different perspectives and ways of
understanding distress which often tend
to be narrative based and I had the
privilege for example of sharing the
framework with people from some very
different cultures recently specifically
from Maori culture in New Zealand and
one of the things that was this was a
very it's a one-off workshop there's a
lot more thinking to do but one of the
things that was very rewarding at that
was to find that actually from a Maori
perspective which of course is
culturally very different very alien to
me
stories are important and although we
were actually using different terms and
different language in some ways we were
saying very similar things there were
two fundamental level there were
commonalities and it felt like a real
Bridget point really in that all human
beings make meaning of the experience
were all storytellers and in terms of
the power threat meaning framework we
all face the impact of power in our
lives we all experience that at times of
a threatening we all try to make meaning
of it and we all try to survive all that
by using what we have called in the
framework threat responses which is kind
of roughly equivalent to what in
psychiatric terms you'd call symptoms so
yeah I think that we need to and maybe
even able to take some small steps
towards drawing back from what I see is
I mean a devastating me overall
unhelpful colonization of people's minds
in cultures that have not yet had the
dubious benefits our Western psychiatric
model but are having it rapidly exported
I'm actually work towards ways of
sharing and understanding each other's
learning neither culture imposing on the
other but both learning for each other
in a process of true collaboration I
guess that would be the ideal
you